[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
remembering george floyd one year after
his death
we speak to his family on how they're
memorializing his legacy
we need change and an exclusive
interview with a mother who accuses
derek chovin of using excessive force on
her 12 year old child with autism
but he had placed his knee on his back
and
close to his neck if not on his neck
plus
defense attorneys for an iowa farm
worker accused of murder call for
justice for victim molly tibbetts
but also suggests police misconduct the
confrontation continues
until it was put in my client's head
perhaps you blacked out and the sister
of the last person to see alive the
missing wife of millionaire real estate
air
testifies at the robert durst murder
trial she was told by susan berman
that she had to go through susan in
order to question bobby
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
may 25th marks one year since george
floyd was murdered
his family and loved ones are using the
day to remember his legacy
video of the 46 year old's death was
seen around the world
one year later former officer derek
chovin stands convicted
and three more officers are awaiting
trial on tuesday
the floyd family met with president
biden and members of congress
they were hoping the george floyd
justice and policing act would have been
passed by may 25th
the bill would ban chokehold and no
knock warrants at the federal level
and create a national database of police
misconduct the house passed the bill
but it appears to have stalled in the
senate over a provision to end
qualified immunity for officers we need
to be able to
set standard procedures in place just
like
we need meaningful legislation uh when
it's time that georgetown
policing that we needed on bible test
the senate would need to get this taken
care of
[Applause]
derek showman is set to be sentenced
next month a mother
is speaking out only to law and crime
about a use of force incident involving
the former minneapolis police officer
law and crime senior investigative
reporter adam classville is here with
the exclusive interview
thank you for having me brian uh as
this interview came out when we
had learned uh this is a for my
podcast objections we air on tuesday and
when we learned
uh when this mother reached out to me
and told me her story and we planned to
air
on this stage she was just pulled over
with the significance
of the fact that there were what she
called some haunting parallels
when derek chauvin had a knee on her 12
year
old child's back the child she said was
having trouble breathing
what made the mother step forward is of
course after derek chovin's conviction
there was another federal civil rights
case uh one of the case involving george
floyd's murder
but another case involving a 14 year old
so
when she learned another 14 year old was
accused of had that derek chovin was
accused of these actions against a 14
year old
she came forward to us with her story
and brought a new dimension of the case
in that her child has autism and this is
of course
coming in the context of a nationwide
conversation about mental health and
policing
the senate judiciary committee had a
hearing of it just
two days after derek chovin's conviction
talking about police responses to mental
health crises
there is a police report that the mother
shared with us
that shows that derek chovin who wrote
the report
was responding to a mental health crisis
and
this she wanted in coming to us with
this story
to shine a light on this particular
issue about mental health and policing
adam i definitely want to continue to
talk more about this but first let's
take a listen
to what the mother had to say
even though the reason for my call was
serious
and when he was down on my child's back
it was like
i was pleading with him and he the way
he turned and looked at me and said this
is what we're doing and then
i like i said i'm fiery i don't back
down very easily and i felt
afraid for my life and certainly for my
kid's life at that moment
because the way that he was responding
to my words
adam i understand she hasn't spoken to
the minnesota attorney general's office
or federal authorities about this
incident you kind of touched on it a
little bit but tell us a little bit more
as to why she's coming forward now
so part of the reason was when this was
happening as i mentioned this was a
mental health crisis
and involving her child there were one
among
many involving her child who suffers
from autism
has bipolar disorder and other
uh and other diagnoses so
she was dealing with a lot of things and
after the video of george floyd came out
she came across what is known as a blue
card
that police distribute to crime victims
and
it set her on this search she was
trump was more than troubled by what had
happened to george floyd
she learned about what happened to the
14 year old actually through the george
floyd case when that originally came out
and it set her upon the search she
obtained the police report
she requested the body cam video
the minneapolis police department told
her they did not
have the video we're trying to get some
answers as to why that's the case
exactly so thank you adam for that
exclusive uh
former minneapolis police officer derek
shovin was convicted of unintentional
murder in floyd's death
law and crimes angela levy spoke with
the floyd family's lawyer
about his upcoming sentencing yeah brian
and i asked ben crump exactly what
sentence
he and george floyd's family believe
that shoving should receive
whatever sentence george floyd would
have received
had the rose being reversed and george
floyd put his knee on derek jovan's neck
for 9 minutes and 29 seconds while he
begged for his life
well then that's the same sentence that
derek shoving should receive
it has always been about equal justice
for us
because we are trying to send the
message
that all marginalized minorities in
america want
the only thing black people want in
america
is equal justice under the law
eric shoving could get as long as 40
years in prison when he is sentenced
next month
he can face that much time because judge
cahill found that there were aggravating
factors that
existed when george floyd died brian
thanks internet let's bring in co-host
terry austin with us as well
terry we know that judge cahill can go
above the statutory limit
for our first offender but how far above
do you think he'll go
you know brian i think he's going to go
as far as he possibly can
we know that children was convicted of
all three counts
in connection with you know second and
third degree murder and manslaughter
and the video itself was particularly
disturbing and i think that's going to
affect the judge
and also as we know there were
aggravating factors here
we know that george floyd was in a
vulnerable position because he was
handcuffed and in the prone position we
think
that this was and i think the judge is
going to think that this was
particularly
cruel that he you know went over
his authority and he abused it and this
was in front of children so i definitely
think that he is going to get as much as
he can
absolutely in an early report judge
cahill found four of the five
aggravating circumstances put forward by
the prosecution
so he has the right to do that and
jeannette how does krump feel
about the federal case going ahead of
the state case against the other three
officers
you know i asked him about that and he
didn't really seem to mind he said that
historically speaking the constitutional
violations have really been
determined by the federal courts and
those are the courts the federal ones
that have actually convicted police
officers of crimes in relation to use of
force and excessive force
so he seemed to be okay with it yeah
seems like more familiar ground for him
when that's
the ground that typically um prosecutes
and also convicts officers he'd probably
be happy to see that
make it easier for the state case thank
you both for your contribution
still ahead on law and crime daily
inside the courtroom of our two live
trials the testimony and evidence you
don't want to miss
but first our special report on the one
year anniversary
of george floyd's death continues how
his family is remembering their brother
their friend and their loved one next
[Music]
welcome back one year after george
floyd's death his family
is continuing their advocacy i spoke
with floyd's brother about a new
organization he's starting in floyd's
memory called
we are floyd
it's been powerful it's been an
emotional roller coaster for terence
floyd losing his older brother last may
ignited a new passion before i was upset
i was angry i was
frustrated now i'm just just eager
optimistic ready to move ready to get
this uh we all floyd off the ground to
better our better
community and our culture taryn says we
are floyd will focus on mental health
care
and financial literacy for inner city
youth the nonprofit is separate from the
george floyd memorial foundation
started last year by members of floyd's
family the officer took
a great man a great father
a great brother he always told me i had
a voice he always wanted to encourage me
to talk
and be more outgoing than i already am
taryn says the death of his brother
pushed him to use his own voice
to fight for social justice i hear
people saying
monte dei mata you know
but i i look at him as my hero
terence's hopeful reform will come
through in the george floyd justice and
policing act
i know it's going to get passed
regardless because
not only us but they see we need change
his sacrifice changed this world it
changed mine
not just as his little brother but me as
a man
communities around the country are
kneeling for nine minutes and 29 seconds
in george floyd's honor anja libya is
back with more from the attorney
for george floyd's family yeah brian ben
crump and i i really talked to him
really about what this last year has
been like and what he'd like to see
happen moving forward
i think about all the progress that was
made in that year
but i have to reflect on all the
progress
that needs to be made to prevent the
unnecessary
the unjustifiable and unconstitutional
killings of black people in america by
the police that has
happened since george floyd was tortured
to death on may 25th
2020.
those feelings um stated by terence
floyd that they would like to see the
george floyd justice and policing act
passed by both houses of congress and
signed into law
the legislators who are actually working
on that bill said that they
uh they released a statement saying that
they are working towards some meaningful
progress
and a compromise on this issue brian
thanks internet let's bring back co-host
terry austin terry
at this point do you think the federal
george floyd bill is a question of
if or when it will pass i certainly hope
it's a question of when we know that
it's already passed as far as the house
is concerned it's the senate
that we have to be concerned about but
it is a very
important bill because it does put some
uniformity behind the laws
it's going to eliminate certain things
it's going to make sure that there's
a limit on unnecessary use of force it's
going to
limit and restrict the use of no knock
warrants and choke holes
and it's going to make sure that there's
a collection of data as relates to
complaints against police officers it's
going to enhance training and it's going
to
give the department of justice more
power
as far as subpoenas are concerned so i
do think it's
very important and i am hoping that the
senate will
pass it and that it will become
legislation
the one thing that seems to be hanging
up the senate is the issue of
qualified immunity we'll see how that
passes through if they can make a
compromise or it goes through as is
and did benjamin crump give you an
impression of how he thought the bill
could impact policing in this country
yeah he said that he basically thinks
that that could be a big step toward
ensuring that people of color are
treated equally
under the law by the police and he
believes it really has some teeth to it
and he said that's all that
african americans in this country want
he said that they want to be treated
equally under the law and that's all
they're asking for it's a very simple
request and he
hopes that that will be done just
looking for equal justice not more
justice makes sense thank you both
coming up on law on crime daily is
cocaine to blame for a missing woman
why robert durst defense team is
pointing the finger at a drug
to explain why his wife disappeared
decades ago
plus the evidence of mollie tibbetts
murder here with the defense of an iowa
farmer worker
accused of killing the college student
is now presenting to a jury ahead
we're back defense attorneys for an iowa
farm worker charged with murdering
a college student molly tibbetts are
beginning their case with a dna expert
angie olivia is back with the testimony
brian dr michael spence examined the dna
test results
from christian behavior rivera's vehicle
the trunk of his vehicle
and dr spence says that he has a
different interpretation of the results
from the crime lab employees who analyze
that data
he focused on dna mixtures found in the
trunk of the black chevy malibu he said
there were four areas of blood
and some of the dna actually came from
an unidentified female
and an unidentified male neither one was
molly tibbetts or christian bahayna
rivera spence said no other dna samples
were provided to the lab to compare the
blood stains so
we simply don't know who that dna came
from or when and how it was left there
there was a clear indication there was
female dna within there
uh that once again
we don't want to confuse that that might
have been mishabits we're talking about
a female other than miss tibbetts
you have no dispute that molly tibbetts
blood and dna was on the trunk seal
of the black chevy malibu that's an
issue in this case
no i don't dispute that at all
and spence said in his review of the
information he did not see any
contamination issues from the dna
samples taken
from the trunk of the car the jury also
heard
from the mother of christian bohena
rivera's daughter that's his
ex-girlfriend
she testified that he had never been
violent toward her
brian thanks angina terry so there's an
unidentified man an unidentified woman
in that trunk in some way
shape or form the defense is obviously
arguing something could they
argue that uh the defendant only buried
molly tibbets and didn't kill her could
that work
you know they could try to make that
argument but i don't think it's going to
work look we know that molly tibbetts
blood was in the area of the trunk
but we also know that no one else
followed molly
no one else said that they fought with
molly
no one else took the authorities to her
body so i think
the blood that is unidentified as a male
and female in the trunk
could belong to a family member so i
don't think that argument that the
defense might
you know put up forth is going to
prevail
so angenette as a character witness how
was the testimony of the mother of the
defendant's child
you know it's really hard to know how
that will play with the jury
she um was very well spoken
but you know she dated him this wasn't
somebody that she was
should they have a child together it's
the mother of his child this isn't
somebody that he
happened upon on the street as is
alleged in this case so we'll just have
to wait and see how
the jury feels about it you know when
and if they reach a verdict
yeah and then of course they'll be
charged as to what an interested witness
is
the mother of his child is probably a
very interested witness
because if he's incarcerated can't
really help out financially or at least
be in the child's life so we'll see how
that plays out
when we come back the sister of kathy
durham's friend testifies
about the last time they saw the missing
mrs durst
welcome back prosecutors are presenting
evidence they say ties the murder of
robert durst's best friend
to the disappearance of his first wife
kathy
the real estate air is accused of
murdering susan berman back in december
of 2000.
prosecutors alleged durst shot berman
because she knew too much
about the disappearance of durha's first
wife kathy in 1982.
the last person to see kathy alive was
goberta neijami
who passed away in 2015. her sister
testified in her place
on cross the defense asked her about
kathy's alleged cocaine use
when i used it and most people around me
including gaberta used it
um when we were going out going out
going out dancing clubs
and you didn't consider yourself a
cocaine addict
not at all but you use cocaine yeah
uh being addicted to cocaine or the use
of cocaine there's two different things
yes right correct
but cocaine can affect uh the way a
person works
right if they use it to excess yes sure
and if you
stay out late one evening dancing using
cocaine the next morning you might not
be the best at work
right that could be true
on redirect prosecutors asked about
kathy's demeanor before she disappeared
when you interacted with kathy on
january 31st
1982 i mean you had some experience
using
cocaine yourself right yes you've been
around other people who've been using
cocaine
yourself yes did it appear to you that
kathy was
acting the way she was because she was
high in cocaine or because she was upset
about a fight she just had with her
husband i don't think that's within her
expertise
i object overall i was not
i did not believe kathy was under the
influence of cocaine
when she came to that house and
basis of opinion overall
why do you think that because
cocaine makes you happy and she wasn't
happy
terry at times the lawyers were hostile
to the witnesses
to each others sometimes even the judge
how is his trial being handled
you know brian i understand that
sometimes it's difficult to
run a courtroom but this is something
i've never seen
judge windham really has lost control of
the courtroom he
allows the attorneys to argue over each
other
and even argue with the witnesses and
especially as it relates to john lewin
the prosecutor i definitely think he
believes he's the judge in this case
because
he oftentimes interjects even if he
hasn't made an objection he just starts
speaking out
and judge windham oftentimes lets him do
that
now terry fireworks are great for tv but
isn't muddying the waters of this case
potentially making it tougher for the
prosecution
i think it is brian there are so many
issues here and there's so many people
involved in this case
and they are spending so much time on
little issues like this phone call
now definitely the defense thinks this
phone call that
allegedly we have susan making on behalf
of kathy and impersonating her but they
spent so much time going back and forth
today i think it really
lost the jury yeah i think they're going
to lose them on some of these finer
points thank you very much terry for
that and thank you for joining us here
at law and crime daily
we'll see you next time as you discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you